many of us are familiar with the
generation and distribution of electric
power only by the plug we insert from
our appliances in order to use it
working backwards the first piece of the
puzzle of power distribution that we
encounter in everyday life
is why plugs have the number of prongs
that they have
some have two
and
some have three
let's start by thinking about plugs with
two prongs
we can explain that the two prongs of
the plugs just by talking about voltage
if you remember that voltage is
potential energy you'll realize that
potential
only has meaning if you measure it
between two things
you need two wires for one to have a
potential value
relative to the other
or conversely we can talk about the two
prongs in terms of current
which you can think of as moving
electric charges or electrons
electrons will only move in a current if
they have somewhere to go
when electrons moved in the static
electricity situation of the van de
graaff
that was only because of the external
force we applied from friction
electrons will not move as current on
their own
down a single conductor
because there would be no way for them
to return
if you think of one prong as current
emerging from the grid
and one prong as current returning
you'll have an accurate mental model of
what's happening
since we are talking about alternating
current
which prong is carrying current in which
direction
switches
60 times a second
when there's a third prong that's also
known as neutral
it's connected to earth ground and it's
there to be sure that the voltage of the
two powered wires doesn't drift
in theory this can't happen but in
reality the two wires could accumulate a
charge that raises the varying current
up by a constant amount
this can represent a danger to certain
electrical appliances
the neutral wire is connected into the
system to keep unwanted charge from
building up
voltage and current are related in fact
what we call electric power is voltage
multiplied by current
in order to have electric power
available to our plugs we first have to
generate it
and our ability to generate electrical
energy really means that we convert it
from another form of energy
this factor rises from a very important
physical law known as conservation of
energy
what this law tells us is that energy
can neither be created or destroyed
only converted from one form to another
conservation of energy was proposed in
the early 1730s
by emily du chatelet in france she was
doing research into the nature of heat
and light
when she realized that different
wavelengths of light were associated
with differing amounts of energy
this information will be very important
to us
as it explains why different colors of
led require different amounts of energy
energy conversion is one of the most
basic phenomena of electrical
engineering
it's surprising how easy it is for me to
say the words that describe electrical
phenomena
but how incredibly powerful this
understanding can be
no pun intended
electrical energy travels through
different media
when we generate and control that energy
we get all of the benefits like
communication entertainment
medical technology and more
in order for electrical energy to move
it has to either be conducted through
some kind of substance that allows its
movement
or it has to be radiated through air and
space as an electromagnetic wave like
light
in order to understand that energy
engineers have developed ways to model
its behavior
we use the models to engineer ways to
control energy
and make it do what we want it to do
let's nail that down
what i just said is actually how a shake
flashlight works
this is a shake flashlight that i made
the tube is just there to hold the coil
of wire
the coil is there to wrap over the
changing magnetic field as many times as
possible
where's the magnetic field
inside the tube is a very strong
neodymium magnet
magnets create magnetic fields around
them naturally
when i shake the tube it causes the
values of the magnetic field at various
points in space to change
which gives us an electric field that
changes over time
getting stronger and weaker as the
magnetic field goes by it
the current can flow along the wire that
i wrapped around here
and then that current is flowing through
this led connected to the wire
when we get enough current the led
lights
it is basically acting as a current
detector for us
i can change how fast i shake the magnet
through the loop of wire and you can
observe the intensity of the light from
the led
what we just saw was a magnetic field
changing in space when the magnet moved
up and down
this changing magnetic field caused an
electric current in the wire
and an electric field that changed over
time as the magnet came and went
next let's look at what happens when we
change a magnetic field in time
this is a small electric motor that
might be found in a model airplane or a
child's toy
it's essentially a loop of wire
surrounding a magnet
and you can see multiple loops of wire
surrounding a set of magnets
here's the outside of a much larger
motor taken out of a blender
where you can see the different loops of
wire
they will allow us to multiply the
output by the number of loops that we
have
when i run current through the outside
loops of wire by attaching a battery to
them
it causes magnetic fields that oppose
the magnetic fields inside of the magnet
this pushes on the magnet inside and
causes the inner piece or the rotor to
turn
and we get a motor
if
instead of putting current in and
getting motion out
we put motion in
by physically turning the motor shaft
we will get current out
i can show you this by attaching a
multimeter
a multimeter is a device that measures
multiple electric quantities which might
cost you anywhere from ten dollars to
two hundred dollars
we can attach this multimeter to the
tabs where i had put the battery before
and use it to measure voltage
the meter reads zero when i first attach
it
then when i begin turning the shaft
myself
you can see a voltage being measured
what you're seeing is energy being
converted from the mechanical energy of
my hand
to electrical energy in the form of
current flowing
now what we have is a generator
so this device is either a motor or a
generator
what it shows us is a magnetic field
that varies over time
when i rotate the shaft that gives rise
to an electric field
that varies over space
which is what we can see as voltage that
i measured
when i demonstrated a van de graaff
generator last time we saw the effects
of charge collecting on the sphere
and then i put some styrofoam on top
what we didn't point out at the time was
that the charges were generating an
electric field which became strong
enough to generate enough force to lift
the styrofoam
the intensity of the field decreased as
it got farther from the sphere
these three demonstrations
illustrate a set of electrical and
magnetic phenomena that underline all of
electrical engineering
and there's one more idea to highlight
the fourth phenomena has to do with
magnetic fields now the easiest way for
me to get a magnetic field is to pick up
a magnet
which generates a permanent electric
field
we can't see the field without help
but
when i pour iron filings over the magnet
they will line up along the lines of the
magnetic field
the lines start on one side of the
magnet
and end on the other
all magnets behave this way they all
have two poles which we call north and
south
we can't have a particle that has only
one pole
they come in pairs
the phenomenon that shows up in these
field lines that they both start and end
on the magnet
shows us a very interesting way that
magnetism differs from electricity
it is that magnetic charges as opposed
to electric charges
don't exist
the field lines of an electric field can
begin on a single charge and radiate
outward
in essence not
terminating magnetic field lines can't
do that
this means the universe is asymmetric
and that tends to bother scientists
to an engineer it means that we cannot
build systems that carry magnetic
currents
in the same way we build systems to
carry electric currents
so what's special about this set of four
demonstrations
they illustrate four very famous
equations now called maxwell's equations
yes
equations
the tool that we use to model the
behavior of electromagnetic energy is
mathematical equations
one of the things that puts some people
off about engineering in general and
electrical engineering specifically is
our tendency to speak in math
and when i say speak in math i really
mean it
mathematics is a language very much like
any other
the most important thing to realize
about it is that just like a native
english speaker has to learn spanish
we all have to learn to speak math at
some point in our lives
so let's speak through the
demonstrations again
and notice this time
that maxwell's four equations are
actually two pairs
the first pair about fields and the
second pair about charges
first
the shake flashlight told us that a
magnetic field changing over space
yields an electric field that changes
over time plus some electric current
this part of the equation that has the
upside down delta stands for the
magnetic field varying in all three
dimensions of space
the part that stands for the electric
field varying
only in time
is written by del dt
to understand something varying in time
but not in space
imagine a time lapse video showing a
seed sprouting
growing and getting leaves
it's varying in time
but not in space because it isn't
traveling
by contrast something varying in space
but not time
is like taking a picture of a field of
sunflowers they won't all be blooming
the same amount
they will vary over the space of the
field
but they won't vary in time
because the picture is a snapshot of a
moment in time
second
the generator demo
showed that a magnetic field
changing over time
produces an electric field
that changes over space
this is something that michael faraday
first noticed in 1831
third
the van de graaff generator demonstrated
that electric charges give rise to an
electric field that varies over space
the field is strongest near the electric
charge and gets weaker as the distance
increases each charge creates an
electric field
because the charges are the same
polarity
the fields oppose each other
which causes a force to be generated
between them
that force is what causes the styrofoam
blocks to move
finally our examination of the magnets
field leads to the fourth idea that
there is no such thing as a magnetic
charge
when electrons carry electric charge
no one has ever found anything that
carries magnetic charge
so the outcome of all this is that
changing electric fields cause changing
magnetic fields
and changing magnetic fields cause
electric fields and current
and the reverse is also true
changing current
causes magnetic fields
that's how we make the shake flashlight
the lack of magnetic charges and thus
the lack of magnetic current
is the only thing that keeps this
phenomena from being completely mirrored
this duality of maxwell's equations is
pretty neat i mean one of the things
they predict is that a motor can be a
generator and vice versa
generators are what is used to convert
energy from other forms into electrical
energy
they're how we get the electric current
that's distributed all over the electric
grid
most generators require some kind of
force to turn the shaft just as i did
with my fingers
then the turbines can be turned by steam
created from heat
now that heat can come from many
different sources
usually by burning them
alternatively the turbines can be turned
by wind or water
this is a generator that was used in an
early power plant at niagara falls
many early generators used coal and many
still do
coal is burned to heat
water
and create steam
that steam turns the turbine which is
connected to the shaft of the generator
the electricity generated is then
conveyed over power lines to end users
in 2019 the us still used coal for about
23 percent of electricity production
while china used coal for 58 percent of
electricity production
natural gas was the largest source of
heat energy for making steam in u.s
electricity production in 2019
at 38 percent of all sources
nuclear was the third most common source
of electrical energy in 2019
all of it nuclear fission
fission separates atoms into less
complex particles and releases nuclear
energy in the process
we use that nuclear energy to convert
hot water into steam
and to create the mechanical energy that
turns a turbine
and the generator shaft to create
electrical energy
there's also hope for nuclear energy by
fusion
which forces simple atoms together into
larger atoms and also releases energy to
create heat to create steam
this is one of the national academy of
engineering's grand challenges for the
21st century
but with solar energy
it's possible to create electrical
energy directly without needing to turn
a turbine and generator as an
intermediary
this
is an example of a photovoltaic or pv
solar cell made out of silicon
pv cells make use of a physical
phenomenon called the photovoltaic
effect
when the photons of light strike certain
types of materials
the hold of these materials on their
electrons is loosened and then the
electrons can be made to move
and become part of an electric current
most solar cells are still made from
silicon
but the materials that make good solar
cells are very much under research
researchers are looking at ways to make
cells flexible robust and cheap because
these cells are very stiff
and can break easily
a cell like this one is combined with
many others into solar panels so that
the currents can get added up into
larger and useful amounts of current
the resulting current can be used to
power devices directly or it can be
incorporated as a source of electricity
onto their electric grid
this can also be done in different ways
the electricity
could be used to drive a motor
which is attached to a generator
alternatively the solar energy can be
used to heat water and drive a turbine
i think you're getting the point right
so why the need for intermediate steps
why can't electricity from solar energy
be added directly onto the grid
well it's because the electricity
produced by solar cells travels in one
direction only
it's direct current or dc
remember how edison westinghouse and
tesla argued about dc versus ac
our electric grid supplies the
alternating current of ac
electricity generated from solar cells
has to be converted from dc to ac
individual homes that are off the grid
could use dc entirely
but most homes that have solar panels on
the roof
usually have a device called an inverter
that converts dc to ac
inverters can range from watts to
megawatts
and their physical size is decreasing
rapidly as we start using new materials
like silicon carbide
now let me show you a few things with
this solar cell that i have here
i'm going to attach a multimeter to the
cell and it will show the voltage that
we get as i shine various colors of
light on it
a measuring voltage
which as we saw before is directly
related to power and energy
the higher the voltage the higher the
energy output
what you see now
is just ambient light from the studio
if i cover the cell we can see the
voltage output drop
white light
contains different proportions of
various light colors depending on its
source
sunlight brings a nearly even
distribution across the visible
frequencies
it also has a fair amount of radiation
at both the shorter wavelengths of
ultraviolet
and the longer wavelengths of infrared
the glass that covers most solar cells
actually blocks ultraviolet radiation
this cell doesn't have glass so we
should be able to see if ultraviolet
will generate electricity
now
let's see if the response changes when i
add glass
now i'll use filters to expose the cell
to one color of light at a time
i'm going to start with the red filter
which will filter out all but the red
light
then a green filter to take out all but
the green light
then a blue filter
to take out all but the blue energy
now if i put all three filters together
the result should be
pretty near zero
because white light is composed of all
the colors
finally let's look again at this
ultraviolet flashlight
this is long-wave ultraviolet sometimes
known as black light and it's the least
dangerous form of ultraviolet
we can see this picks up ultraviolet a
very well
uvb is more energetic
but a lot of uvb is blocked by the
earth's atmosphere
uvc is the most dangerous to life which
is why germicidal lamps are made with
uvc
but uvc is entirely blocked by the
earth's atmosphere so solar cells on
earth can ignore it
of course human-made light sources do
not come anywhere near sunlight in the
energies they offer across different
frequencies
solar cells made of different materials
differ in their ability to convert
various frequencies of sunlight
in fact one reason you might prefer a
specific solar cell over another is its
ability to use a wider range of
frequencies of light
indeed one of the ways that solar cells
are inefficient is in whether they're
able to convert light to electricity
across the entire available spectrum of
their light sources
in the year 2020 even the most efficient
solar cells were only about 20 efficient
this is another reason that researchers
are looking at how to make solar cells
from different types of materials
even studying the natural process of
photosynthesis used by leaves to convert
solar energy to other types of energy
engineers have already developed a huge
variety of ways to generate electricity
and you can expect more in the future
what is important to remember is that
the results of these efforts is the same
as far as the electricity is concerned
they create a flow of electrical current
that then has to be distributed to the
people that need to use it
but how does the electrical energy get
from generators to my house
in the next lesson we'll learn about the
electric grid its origins and how the
new smart grid will carry us into the
future